ça c'est une paire de basket et comme ça
arrive à 80 % des Français j'ai décidé
de la commander sur
internet si vous aussi vous avez été
dans ce cas-là peut-être qu'on vous a
déjà dit franchement tu devrais arrêter
la livraison ça pollue un max du coup je
me suis poser la question est-ce que
c'est pas plus écolo finalement de se
faire livrer ses chaussures plutôt que
d'aller les acheter en magasin parce que
jusqu'ici j'avais lu tout es son
contraire d'un côté certaines ONG
présentent la livraison comme une
catastrophe écologique de l'autre des
entreprises notamment de e-commerce
vendent une meilleure option pour la
planète notamment parce que ça
permettrait d'optimiser les transports
récemment une étude a répondu à cette
question on y découvre que ce qui pollue
le plus entre la livraison et la vente
en magasin ça peut être l'un ou l'autre
en fait tout ça va dépendre des choix
des e-commerçant et aussi des nôtres
vous allez voir c'est vraiment un
secteur qui a explosé ces dernières
années complètement renforcé boosté par
la crise covid pour ce nouvel épisode de
la grande explication j'ai donc creusé
dans quel cas c'est mieux pour la
planète de faire livrer que d'acheter en
magasin quelles peuvent-être les
solutions individuelles et collectives
pour réduire l'impact de ces colis je
vous
explique cette histoire elle commence
ici avec le fameux suivi de commande de
mes baskets j'ai voulu voir concrètement
comment chacune de ces étapes pouvait
polluer plus ou moins en fonction de ce
qui se passe derrière pour ensuite
pouvoir comparer tout ça à l'option
magasin mon colis c'est loin d'être une
exception 4 millions de colis seraient
livrés chaque jour en France selon
laadem avec des pics à 100 par jour lors
des fêtes de fin d'année ou du Black
Friday on est donc sur des impacts pour
l'environnement bien plus grands
qu'éteindre la lumière quand on quitte
une pièce ou supprimer quelques emails
rigolo les émissions liées au à ces
transports aux emballages au
déplacements pour tous ces colis sont de
l'ordre d'un million de tonnes de CO2
par an en France et 1 million de tonnes
de CO2 ça représente environ 400000
aller-retour en avion de Paris à New
York regardons donc ce qu'il y a
derrière le parcours de mes
baskets cette commande comme beaucoup
elle commence par des recherches sur
internet l'achat sur le site de vente et
l'envoi d'email alors oui ces étapes
numériques elles ont un impact sur
l'environnement mais il reste bien plus
faible que le reste des étapes du
parcours en fait la première chose qui
va avoir un poids sur l'environnement
elle commence à la préparation de la
commande à ce moment-là autour de
l'emballage de base l'expéditeur peut
choisir d'ajouter une couche en
plastique ou alors un deuxième carton
plus grand comme dans cet autre colis il
peut aussi mettre des bout de
polystyrène ou d'autres matériaux pour
caler l'ensemble et ça regardons ce que
ça change pour le climat selon laadem
pour un même colis livré à domicile
voici l'emprinte carbone totale estimée
pour une option avec un suremballage en
carton si ce suremballage est une
enveloppe plastique l'empreinte carbone
est légèrement plus faible et pour une
option sans suremballage cela divise
presque l'impact total par de et puis
vous l'avez sans doute constaté vous
aussi certains colis contiennent pas mal
de vides en moyenne on pense qu'on est à
plus de 50 % de vide entre l'article
commandé lui-même et le volume global du
carton pu il y a de couches ou de vide
et plus ça fait en amont plus
d'emballage à produire et à la fin plus
de déchets et avec tout ça ma paire de
chaussures elle peut vite prendre plus
de place dans les
[Musique]
transports en fait d'une livraison à
l'autre la route suivie par ces
chaussures peut-être très différente
Chine ce site de vente de vêtements vous
connaissez l'ONG Suiss public a révélé
que pour livrer plus rapidement ses
clients l'enseigne avait recours à de
nombreux avions cargo en 2021 c'est
Amazon qui annoncé le rchat de 11 Boeing
767 300 afin selon l'entreprise de
garder le rythme pour tenir les
promesses à nos clients
traditionnellement la grande
distribution a toujours été
approvisionnée par conteneur maritime
depuis l'Asie là avec le commerce en
ligne on voit un développement de
d'usage du transport aérien résultat
selon laadem Voici la différence entre
une livraison de chaussures sans
transport en avion et la même livraison
si elle intègre une étape en avion
l'empreinte carbone totale elle est
multipliée par 4 voire plus dans
certains
cas mes chaussures lors du stockage ou
entre plusieurs étapes de transport
elles vont passer par plusieurs types de
grands entrepôts et comme il y a de plus
en plus de ventes en ligne on doit en
construire de plus en plus 200000 m²
50000 m² 100000 m² 150000 m² on est sur
des emprises au sol très importantes
dans le cadre d'une nouvelle
réglementation liée au zéro
artificialisation net on a plutôt
tendance à essayer de faire en sorte que
les ces nouvelles constructions soient
plutôt dirigées vers d'ancienne friches
voilà ça c'est c'est idéal bon pour être
tout à fait complet la logistique des
grandes surfaces ou d'autres magasins ça
contribue aussi à la multiplication des
entrepôts d'ailleurs certains les
partagent avec le e-commerce si on se
concentre uniquement sur le commerce en
ligne à l'échelle nationale France
stratégie estime qu'entre 2000 et 2019
les différents entrepôts ont grignoté
entre 80 et 90 hectares par an ce qui
fait environ 120 terrains de football
chaque année revenons à moncolis sur sa
route il peut suivre plus ou moins
d'étapes de transport jusqu'à sa tournée
finale une chaîne de transport est plus
ou moins polluante en fonction du mode
de trans transport que vous allez
utiliser est-ce qu'il y a du vélo est-ce
qu'il y a du transport électrique ou
est-ce que c'est que du thermique si
elle est plus ou moins longue évidemment
si vous faites venir un produit de Chine
c'est pas pareil que si vous faites
venir un produit de Bourgogne mais
au-delà de la distance c'est aussi nous
ce qu'on va regarder c'est la tonne
kilomèt c'est-à-dire le le volume de
marchandise transporté par rapport à la
distance ce qui fait qu'aujourd'hui par
ailleurs le transport maritime est très
compétitif parce que vous transportez
beaucoup énormément même sur des longues
distances à ce momentl ces chaussures
vont bientôt arriver chez moi et une
partie du poids écologique passe
maintenant entre mes
mains déjà ce que je me demandais
vraiment c'est si c'était plus poant de
se faire livrer directement chez moi ou
alors d'aller chercher ce colis dans un
point de retrait toujours selon l'ADEM
ça c'est l'empreinte carbone d'une
livraison optimisée à domicile j'avais
pas ça en tête mais dans l'étude les
scénarios qui impliquent d'aller
chercher le colis en point de retrait en
voiture ils ont un plus gros impact si
on y va en transport en commun c'est un
peu moins et si je vais chercher ma
commande à pied ou à vélo alors là on
arrive un peu en dessous de la livraison
à domicile si on utilise une voiture
pour se rendre en point de retrait sur
une distance même courte tout de suite
le le l'avantage va basculer en faveur
de la la solution de livraison à
domicile chacun se déplace
individuellement alors que là on a une
livraison un transport de marchandise
collectif du côté de la livraison à
domicile il y a deux cas qui peuvent
augmenter l'impact de mon colis d'abord
si je ne suis pas chez moi au moment de
la livraison ça entraîne un échec de
livraison et une deuxième tournée
ensuite si ces chaussures ne me vont pas
ou ne me plaisent pas et que je décide
de les
renvoyer en France l'ADEM estime que ce
type de retour concerne 20 à 30 % des
commandes de e-commerce contre 8 %
seulement pour le commerce classique les
émission de la livraison et ben elles
vont être doublées par les émissions du
retour et tout ça sans avoir la perte de
chaussures donc tout ça pour rien quoi
des médias et des associations ont même
révélé que certaines cienes de
e-commerce détruisaient des produits
électroniques ou des bêtement retourné
c'est plus facile sur le plan économique
aujourd'hui de détruire un stock que de
conserver un stock d' morts c'est-à-dire
des marchandises dont on sait qu'ils
NEET trouveront pas preneur et qu'il va
falloir conserver dans un entrepôt
pendant une durée indéterminée il y a la
loi AGC de 2021 notamment qui interdit
la destruction de ces invendus les
entreprises elles-mêmes essayent en tout
cas pour la majorité d'entre elles de de
changer de de paradigme par rapport à ça
maintenant il est temps de faire le
bilan de tous ces impacts et de comparer
avec l'achat en
magasin on l'a vu avec mes baskets
beaucoup de choses peuvent changer
l'impact final d'une livraison pour
tenter de comparer tout ça laadem a
retenu six scénarios de livraison à
domicile suremballage carton absence de
suremballage suremballage plastique et
taux de chargement élevé échec de
livraison retour du produit et enfin
trajet en partie en avion s'ajoute à ça
quatre scénarios de livraison en point
retrait avec des placement en voiture
dédié ou non en en transport en commun
et à pied ou à vélo enfin ils ont
comparé avec l'empreinte carbone de
l'achat en magasin donc pareil avec le
déplacement en voiture dédié ou non le
transport en commun ou le vélo
ok mais qu'est-ce qu'on peut retenir de
tout ça déjà selon laadem le magasin dès
qu'il nécessite un trajet en voiture ça
va être une moins bonne option pour le
climat à l'inverse la livraison elle
peut être pire que le magasin si elle
implique un trajet en avion ou quand
elle nécessite elle aussi un déplacement
dédié jusqu'à un point relais en
voiture les trois meilleures options
semblent donc être d'abord l'achat en
magasin lorsqu'on y va à pied ou à vélo
suivi de près par la livraison en point
de retrait si on s'y rend à vélo et
enfin la livraison à domicile sans
suremballage je vous mets bien sûr le
lien de l'étude en description pour que
vous puissiez voir tout ça en détail
jusqu'ici on a comparé la livraison ou
le magasin mais une question qu'on peut
se poser c'est est-ce que tous les
achats en ligne viennent remplacer des
achats qui aurait été fait sinon en
magasin est-ce que finalement je vais
pas acheter cette paire en ligne parce
qu'elle me plaisait et que dans quelques
semaines je vais en racheter une autre
en magasin et donc j'aurais à la fois
pollué pour une livraison et pour un
achat en magasin là aussi c'est ça
dépend aujourd'hui vous allez peut-être
acheter ben vos vêtements sur tel
enseigne tel site vos livres ici vos
courses alimentaires en partie en
physique en partie en ligne donc on va
être sur des choses beaucoup plus
fragmentées on comprend bien que ça
accroit l'offre et que ça met à
disposition en permanence sans sans
contrainte ni ni d'horaire ni de jours
d'ouverture donc ça contribue
certainement à à croître euh la la
consommation mais le commerce en ligne
permet de de cibler exactement ce que
l'on cherche et on peut être finalement
peut-être moins tenté que si l'on fait
les magasins et que l'on voit d'autres
choses auxquelles on n'avait pas pensé
ok mais une fois qu'on a dit ça on va
voir les pistes de solution pour essayer
de moins détruire
l'environnement d'abord adeln hates elle
m'a rappelé que l'impact de la livraison
c'était qu'une partie de l'impact global
d'un achat à côté il y a la production
et la fin de vie du produit lui-même par
exemple dans dans le cas de chaussures
la livraison ça représente entre 1 et 10
% de l'empreinte carbone globale le
meilleur moyen d'avoir un impact carbone
neutre pour une paire de chaussures
c'est encore de pas commander la paire
de chaussures ce qui est facile à dire
évidemment c'est pas c'est pas du tout
moralisateur mais c'est c'est la réalité
à partir du moment où vous allez avoir
un produit qui est transporté il va
avoir un impact carbone en tant que
client si on veut commander et réduire
l'impact de la livraison on peut si
c'est possible privilégier les options
les moins pollantes qu'on a vu sur le
graph de laad le truc c'est qu'aller un
point de retrait à vélo ou à pied on n
pas tous les mêmes possibilités de le
faire c'est par exemple beaucoup plus
difficile dans le village où j'ai
grandis dans la ville où je travaille
actuellement tout simplement parce qu'il
y a beaucoup moins de points de retrait
et c'est pour ça par exemple que l'ADEM
propose de rajouter des points de
retrait en zone rural et au-delà des
marches de manœuvre individuelle j'ai
voulu savoir comment les autorités et
les professionnels peuvent agir à plus
grande échelle c'est 90 % quasiment du
transport de marchandise qui se fait par
la route en France donc une solution qui
apparaît très facile entre guillemets
c'est se dire on a qu'à mettre les
marchandises qui étaient initialement
sur des camions et les mettre sur des
véhicules décarbonés moins polluants on
va retrouver aussi tout ce qui concerne
l'organisation et l'optimisation des
tournées ils peuvent proposer aussi des
produits plus durables et réparables euh
ils peuvent diminuer les quantités les
volumes d'emballage ils peuvent donc
chercher à limiter les les surfaces
artificialisé et donc à ne pas
contribuer à avoir à la fois de plus en
plus de surface commerciale de cent
commerciaux et en même temps de plus en
plus d'entrepôts donc effectivement la
lig la liste est longue côté côté
[Musique]
professionnel pour cette vidéo je me
suis concentré sur l'environnement mais
bien sûr le e-commerce peut aussi
entraîner des transformations en terme
d'emploi de fiscalité sur les petits
commerces ou aussi répondre à des
besoins spécifiques du côté de
l'environnement j'ai beaucoup parlé
d'empreinte carbone parce que c'était
surtout ce que mettait en avant l'ADEM
dans son étude mais on aurait pu parler
de rejet de pollant qui ont des
conséquences sur la santé aussi par
exemple sur ces particules là on voit
que les conclusions sont quand même
souvent assez proches de celles du CO2
et comme presque toujours voici une info
bonus qui m'a intéressé si vous utilisez
un livreur à vélo très bien encore
faut-il que ça soit un livroir à vélo
qui travaille dans des conditions
socio-économiques acceptables si quelque
part on économise sur le dos du
travailleur euh de l'argent pour
permettre pour se permettre de payer un
loyer dans un environnement urbain très
dense euh pour pouvoir mettre en place
ce système ce système là voilà là la
question de la durabilité du modèle sur
le plan à la fois environnemental et et
social se pose je seraai très heureux de
répondre à vos questions ou remarques
dans les commentaires et si vous avez
appris des trucs n'hésitez pas à liker
ou partager la vidéo pour que d'autres
personnes la voient aussi vous pouvez
retrouver tous les autres épisodes
précédent de la grande explication juste
ici et ici vous pouvez vous abonner à la
chaîne brut pour découvrir d'autres
formats j' remercier vraiment toutes les
équipes de brut qui permettent chaque
semaine de sortir ces vidéos on se
retrouve dimanche prochain à 11h et
d'ici là je vous dis à
bientôt